bonsoir coblence raison merci d'être
avec nous l'expulsion de l'ambassadrice
de l'union européenne
est-ce que c'est finalement vraiment une
riposte aux sanctions prises ce lundi
par l'union européenne à l'encontre du
venezuela où peut-on y voir une autre
lecture
oui c'est une riposte bien entendu un
peu un peu brutale et certainement
symbolique aux mesures décidées par
l'union européenne de réduire la liberté
d'accès au territoire de l'union
européenne pour 19 personnalités
vénézuélienne et bien sûr comme vous la
victoire
si on ajoute celles qui avaient été
sanctionnés plus tôt dans pour d'autres
sujets en tout il ya cinquante cinq
personnalités vénézuélienne qui ne
peuvent plus avoir de visa schengen ni
de comptes bancaires dans l'union
européenne
j'imagine d'ailleurs qu'elles viennent
rarement dans l'union européenne et que
si elles avaient un compte en banque
quelque part en europe il serait depuis
longtemps partie ailleurs probablement
en asie
mais cela dit c'est vrai que le
parlement européen s'est senti visé par
ces sanctions
puisque les dix neuf personnalités qui
ont été qui ont été visés hier et bien
parmi elles il ya deux parlementaires et
le motif général de ses 19 sanctionné
c'est le fait que les élections
législatives du 6 décembre dernier on
était un peu particulière particulière
pourquoi parce que les partis
d'opposition avait des skis décidé de
boycotter cette élection et que par
conséquent il ya eu 70 % d'abstention
donc les députés ont été élus par 30%
des électeurs et bien entendu dans ces
conditions 90% des sièges ont été
attribués au parti de monsieur maduro et
lui ont fait n'est pas est pas la seule
à critiquer cette pratique les états
unis le canada mais aussi des pays
d'amérique latine comme la colombie ou
comme le panama ont également fortement
critiqué cette pratique un peu
particulière les élections législatives
alors maintenant madame isabelle bryant
et doit partir d'ici samedi
sauf si sauf si monsieur bayrou se
ravise
car c'est le deuxième essai de monsieur
magro il avait déjà il avait déjà donné
la même peine à madame brillante et au
mois de juin dernier le 29 juin
ils lui avaient donné 72 heures pour
quitter le territoire et puis pour des
raisons diverses il s'est ravisé
deux jours plus tard et elle a pu rester
cette fois ci ça sera sans doute plus
difficile compte tenu en effet de la
position prise par le parlement et qui
sont en fait les partisans de monsieur
magro qui sont sa base politique et il
est possible que cette fois ci sur une
major ou ne revienne pas sur cette
décision
mais la délégation que dirigeait madame
brillante et pour le moment n'est pas
expulsé n'est pas fermée et continuera à
travailler y compris sur les questions
humanitaires qui intéresse beaucoup les
vénézuéliens alors quelle conséquence l
expulsion d'isabelle brillante et
pedrosa
la tentation à bruxelles si monsieur
malraux ne revient pas sur sa décision
ce sera sans doute celle de toute
diplomatie c'est la réciprocité c'est à
dire de retirer son agrément à
l'ambassadrice du venezuela auprès de
l'union européenne
il se trouve que c'est aussi une femme
d'ailleurs paraît-il tout à fait
remarquable et qui est également
accrédité auprès de la belgique et du
luxembourg
donc s'il y avait s'il devait y avoir un
retrait de son accréditation auprès de
l'union européenne
elle pourrait cependant rester
évidemment à bruxelles puisqu'elle est
accrédité auprès du gouvernement belge
et du gouvernement du grand duché de
luxembourg
je ne vois pas beaucoup d'autres
conséquences puisque encore une fois
comme je vous le disais sauf si le
gouvernement vénézuélien demandé la
fermeture complète de la mission de
l'union européenne
les gens qui travaillaient avec madame
brillante et continueront de travailler
sur leurs différents sujets qui sont des
sujets de coopération avec les
vénézuéliens et par ailleurs les
ambassades des états membres
naturellement continue de fonctionner et
les ambassadeurs sont toujours sont
toujours en place heureusement
heureusement d'ailleurs
alors une crise diplomatique certes mais
les vénusiens lévénez et j'ai eu un holà
là je vais y arriver vénézuélien dans
tout ça écoutez c'est assez simple
actuellement il ya encore 30 millions de
vénézuéliens
mais il y a cinq ans il y en avait 35 en
fait 5 millions sont partis un million
et demi sont dans le pays voisin ils
sont réfugiés en colombie il n'est pas
pourtant un pays de tout repos mais ils
ont préféré quitter le venezuela
et puis d'autres sont partis vers des
pays plus lointains certains vers
l'europe en passant par l'espagne
puisque ils ont en commun la langue
espagnole et les vénézuéliens sont
aujourd'hui le venezuela est aujourd'hui
le deuxième pays d'origine des
demandeurs d'asile dans l'union
européenne ce qui est un véritable
problème pour l'union européenne et
c'est la situation politique et
économique du venezuela
il crée ce flux de départs vers des
horizons les horizons plus plus plus
souriants ou plus accueillants et
effectivement on peut on peut dire que
le venezuela a perdu 60 % de son produit
national brut en cinq ans ce qui est
énorme que l'année dernière en 2020 la
monnaie vénézuélienne a connu une
inflation gigantesque d'ailleurs
inimaginable 3000% d'inflation ce qui
est lu nulle part ailleurs et le fmi a
d'ailleurs refusé de concéder à un prêt
ou une aide au venezuela
alors que monsieur maduro demandait au
mois de mai dernier cinq milliards de
dollars et le fmi a dit qu'aucune des
conditions étaient remplies pour que
c'était de soin accordé au venezuela
donc le venezuela dans une situation
économique dramatique
avec une industrie pétrolière autrefois
florissante qui aujourd'hui est
totalement obsolète
aucun investissement n'a été fait par
conséquent toutes les machines sont
obsolètes et la productivité très
faibles
et c'est la même chose dans d'autres
secteurs de l'économie un jour
évidemment le venezuela aura besoin de
l'aide de pays extérieurs pour rétablir
son économie pour rétablir la
productivité dans le domaine pétrolier
et dans les autres domaines et
économique
merci blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales